it's great to welcome to the program
today dean baker who's a senior
economist at the center for economic and
policy research
also a visiting professor at the
university of utah uh so great to talk
to you dean
it's good to be on thanks for having me
so to start with there's so many areas
i'm curious uh
about your take on that are relevant to
sort of recent
um political economic discussions we
could talk about automation there's the
debt and deficit football that is often
in the news
there is the discussion of uh what are
we heading towards a recession and how
would we know when we are in it but
maybe to figure out what you think might
be most most productive
is there a particular area where you
believe that the sort of
corporate mainstream discussion and
framing of an economic topic
is just way off where we need to like
completely realign even how we're
thinking of the parameters of the debate
yeah there actually is it's an area that
i've worked on kind of as a spare
time thing for really decades and that
this is patent and copyrights
that's going to sound obscure to people
and that's a big problem
because pens and copyrights are hugely
hugely important in the economy
and just to put it as simply as possible
there's a very
commonly held view certainly among
economists and people in policy
discussions
that technology is responsible or at
least partly responsible for upward
redistribution of income so the idea is
that
you have these people in stem people do
computer work or you could point to a
bill gates
you know they they get really rich and
it's just because of technology and then
you have
you know the people who have less
education we'll say people will use
college degrees as a cut off that's
still about two-thirds of the workforce
who don't have college degrees
and they end up as being losers so
classic story someone working on the
assembly line
at uaw uh in an auto factory that
that used to be a good paying job you
could support a family on it you have
health care insurance a pension
well those jobs just aren't that
valuable anymore and the story goes this
this is you know i might say it's
unfortunate it's technology
and the point about patents and
copyrights are those are government
policies
and those determine who are the winners
who get the benefits
from technology and just to go back to
our friend bill gates
bill gates is incredibly rich because he
has copyrights
patents also on microsoft software the
government will
arrest people who use microsoft software
without his permission now that debt is
a policy
we it obviously serves a purpose we have
patents who have copyrights
provide incentive for innovation
incentive for creative work
but that's a policy to do it and the
point is
they could be stronger they could be
weaker they could be
shorter we could have weaker penalties
stronger penalties for violating them
and there are alternatives we already
fund
an awful lot of creative innovative work
and most importantly
national institutes of health we could
fund more that way
so dean i just want to make sure i'm
understanding what you're saying there's
this idea
when we talk about tech jobs jobs for
people with or without college degrees
the sort of potential of these different
types of jobs and very often
the sort of fate of those decisions is
maybe too much attributed to the choices
that the individual makes about
going or not going to college the type
of field that they want to work in but
what you're saying is that with regard
to the technology
the potential of technology jobs that
rather than being a sort of
virtue of the decisions made by the
individual
it's the framework established around
intellectual property by the government
that has kind of created this
environment to begin with
exactly so the fact that there's a lot
of money
in the tech sector that's a policy
decision and again you can even say it's
a good policy decision that's that
that's fine
but the point was this didn't just
happen so when we get all these people
sort of going
you know we really feel bad for those
people who are left behind you go well
they weren't left behind we
pushed them behind i'm curious about
so okay here's an example question
that's often asked
uh that we could even either answer as
asked or we could point out that the
framing is the wrong framing so there's
this question of the gap
between ceo pay and average worker pay
at corporations
if i ask my former university of
massachusetts economic professor richard
wolff
about what is the correct ratio between
ceo pay and average worker pay
he would say the entire system is
screwed up we need to be looking at
democratizing the workplace
the right he would have a systemic
critique rather than one of just saying
well it should be limited to like 100x
or something like that
how does someone like you approach a
question like that of ceo pay to average
worker pay
well i'm fine with the more systemic uh
critique you know i'd be fine with
having workers have more say in the way
companies are running everything
yeah but i think there's an important
misconception about the current system
that you know i sort of say
i i guess my view is always if you can't
take small steps the idea you're somehow
going to take a big leap is
at least to me fairly unlikely so one of
the points i've made about ceo pay
is it's coming at the expense of
shareholders so there was a big deal
made
about a month or so ago the business
roundtable that includes
all the major companies jp morgan's in
there and
bill gates and microsoft all the big
companies are in there
they said oh we should no longer be
concerned with just maximizing
shareholder value
we have to be concerned about our
workers about the environment about the
community
would you go okay those are all good
things but the point i made was
you were not just concerned about
maximizing shareholder value you were
concerned about maximizing ceo pay
ceo pay has gone up 940 percent over the
last four decades
and you know guess what returns to
shareholders over the last two decades
actually have been very poor
by historic standards you could argue
what they should get i mean that's
open question but the point is returns
to shareholders in the last two decades
have actually been really weak
by historic standards so if they've been
maximizing shareholder value
they do a really bad job of it so my
point is that what's going on with ceos
is that basically they're ripping off
their shareholders and that's because of
the structure of corporate governance
the people who determine their pay
are their boards of directors who are
most immediately responsive to the ceos
so again i'd be happy to see workers
have more say in the way corporations
are run
but i would just settle for having
shareholders have more say in the way
corporations are run because ceos will
get an awful lot less money
and that affects the distribution of
wages up and down the economy because if
the co is getting 20 million in many
cases they are
person right underneath them the chief
financial officer the other top people
they're probably getting 10 12 million
the third tier is getting two or three
million and back where i learned my
arithmetic if those people are getting
more
everyone else must be getting less
because that's taking a big chunk of the
corporate pawn
you said something at the beginning of
of this topic which is
if we can't take small steps it's not
totally logical to think that we could
take the really big steps and this is a
conversation i've had very often as
someone
myself who identifies as a social
democrat with those who
who designate themselves as socialists
who want socialization of the means of
production
and and want to go way further than i
want to go and i've pointed out
it seems to me that in the immediate
what you want
is not even a possibility and that what
you want is only going to happen
if we first get to what i want so really
we should be working together rather
than disagreeing about what the
end point is is that a reasonably
pragmatic in your mind when it comes to
a lot of these economic questions or am
i maybe missing some other component
here
i think that's very very much on the
line because on the mark because
the reality is we could all think of you
know sort of grand visions that we would
like to see the world
uh look like but those are going to be
really really hard to get to and if all
we're thinking of is the grand vision
well
odds are we're not going to make any
progress and you know people are living
their lives and
if they go without health care that's a
really big deal
so we could have our grand vision but
they're not getting health care if we're
not doing anything to address
climate change you know again we could
have our grand vision of what the world
should look like but
you know if we're obsessed with them
we're not thinking okay what can we do
tomorrow what can we do that's going to
have an impact now ideally you have a
longer term strategy so you aren't just
doing things randomly like oh
this is a good thing to do tomorrow and
then well something else to do the next
day
you do have some framework in which
these these steps make sense
but to just say oh i have my grand
vision end of story well
then you're going to be talking about
your grand vision and basically doing
nothing i guess to defend the view of
those who have a more
you might have to tear it down to build
it back up the right way mentality
they would maybe argue that when you
look at some of the major
economic issues uh including for example
inequality the disproportionate power of
corporations
over our daily lives in endless
different ways
when you ask what are the really big
issues here it's not
crazy to think that unless you really
do away with the power structures that
got us to where where we are
we will never have the bigger change and
maybe that's how someone would defend
focusing on the grand vision rather than
what we can do right now
well i have to say that one really
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
because the idea is somehow we're going
to have it all come crashing down i mean
that's
that's as i'm sorry i just think that's
crazy wishful thinking and
you know at the end of the day that
means we're not doing anything that
we're not addressing really important
issues you know so um
we're going to hope it keeps coming
it'll come crashing down in the meantime
we're going to destroy the planet with
you know throwing out so much greenhouse
gas emissions that
you know it's a i'm not going to say
it's never irreversible but
it's it will devastate you know life as
we know it i i that doesn't make sense
to me
when it comes to the discussions of
recession um
what what is your barometer for
determining
if an economy is in a recession is it
that
important to make that determination um
in in any kind of definitive way if
qualitatively you can
identify things that are going well and
things that are not going so well
what's your general sense of the way
that discussion has been carried out
well the conventional view of recession
two quarters of negative growth
um that's not two consecutive course of
negative growth that's not rigorously
defined i mean in other words the 2001
recession we actually didn't have two
consecutive quarters of negative growth
but in any case
to my view whether we're technically in
a recession or not may at the end of the
day not be that important because the
big issues are
things like well basically do people
have jobs are people seeing rising real
wages
um do people feel they can quit their
job if they don't like it
because there's a strong labor market
that can quit their job and get another
job somewhere else
those those are what i think of as big
things and
right now the economy the labor market
looks reasonably good
if it weakens if we start to see the
unemployment rate go up a lot
and we start to see wages slow
that's a big problem whether or not
we're in a recession so
whether we could technically say okay
negative growth it's a recession
that won't matter if it turns out to be
the case that
workers the unemployment rate's rising
and workers lose their ability to secure
wage gains
there's this indicator that i've looked
a little bit at which is
kind of a proxy indicator to what may be
coming
which is the percentage of people who
are 90 days or more behind on car
payments the idea being that
one's ability to stay current on car
payments relates to a lot of
other elements of the economy being able
to get to work which often depends on
that job and that there
there may be some reasonable way in
which it's a proxy indicator to what may
be upcoming
whether or not you want to comment on
that particular metric
do you believe that there are advanced
measures
advanced metrics that are more relevant
to figuring out whether
a recession is coming than others or are
is anybody who's telling you these are
the three things you want to look at
over simplifying
well when i look back at the recessions
post
post world war ii um there are common
features they're basically two stories
with post-world war ii recessions
one is that we start to see higher
inflation
the fed raises interest rates to counter
that tries to slow the economy
and they go too far so when they raise
rates that causes people to buy fewer
cars buy fewer houses they stop
refinancing mortgages
um all those things dampen growth and
you know if they go too far then it
gives you a recession the other way you
get a recession is when a bubble burst
and that's of course what happened in
2008 2009 where the housing bubble burst
and gave us a very severe recession
that was also really the story of the
2001 recession that we had the stock
bubble burst and
uh technically that's not considered a
serious recession i considered a bad one
because if you look at the labor market
we continue to lose jobs the recession
officially ends in december of 2001
we continue to lose jobs all through
2002 and most of the way through 2003
and we didn't get back the jobs we lost
until january 2005. so
to my view that was a serious recession
but long and short when we're looking
for cues
you know advanced warning the two
stories one do we have a bubble that's
about to to burst
and for that you know i don't i don't
see any bubbles there driving the
economy and i did see both the stock
bubble and housing bubbles so
you know i do look for things like that
i don't see anything there now
the other story is the fed raising
interest rates aggressively well
we never got the interest rate all that
high no donald trump was yelling about
it but
you know the interest rate the fed's
interest rate never got above two and a
half percent that just lowered it twice
i i don't see either story of a
recession so the classic
um causality for a recession the fed or
a bursting bubble it's just not there so
i i really don't see one on the horizon
looking forward the topic of automation
is getting more and more attention when
it comes to the presidential race uh
it's been mostly uh andrew yang who has
been talking about it and i've read some
pieces
saying that this is an overblown fear
that in the same way that in the past
technology has destroyed some jobs and
industries but always created more
that that will continue to happen on the
other hand there are
papers i've read which say the rate at
which
that has happened in the past is
changing and over time
technology will destroy more jobs than
the number it creates
possible to know that at this point in
time what's your sense of the importance
of this automation issue
well what i find ironic and i just did a
little paper looking at productivity and
the share portion of productivity growth
that's going to to workers
and first point out is we've actually
we're actually a period of
extraordinarily weak productivity growth
so for all the talk of automation
if you actually look at the data we're
actually losing jobs to technology at a
historically low rate you know i know
all these people i know a lot of people
push that argument they go we have all
this great technology and
maybe it is great but the fact is it's
not affecting the economy
so the idea that we're about to lose all
these jobs to technology
i just see basically zero basis for that
and
if it did happen i mean if we were to
see a more rapid rate of productivity
growth that would be great that would
create a possibility of more rapid wage
growth we could work fewer hours
i just i this is store a story with
basically no reality whatsoever to it so
it's not one of the things that keeps me
up at night what is the thing that keeps
you up at night when it comes to the
economy
well i'd have to say with the economy uh
i don't know what you want to call the
economy or not i mean global warming is
a huge huge
issue and you know we're doing nothing
on it i mean uh
you know donald trump seems to think
it's a good thing to put his
throw as much greenhouse gases into the
environment as possible
and unfortunately the us is still such a
big actor in the world that
if we just ignore any efforts to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions it makes it a
really big problem and of course it
makes you know other countries you know
obviously are looking to us and not you
know you could say as a leader but the
other point is
well if we're out there spewing as much
greenhouse gases as we can into the
atmosphere
probably doesn't make sense for you know
france or germany or
uk to do anything because it won't
matter um so
that that is you know to my view far
away the most pressing thing and i'm
hugely concerned about inequality and
you know what bothers me is we don't
discuss the issue the right way i was
going on about patents and copyrights
i raised this with economists and they
look at me blank-faced it's not that i
think economists are brilliant people
but this is their topic
and the idea that we can't you know they
they'll give me this story about
oh offered income upward redistribution
of income that's unfortunate but that's
just technology
and they go well suppose we do have
patents and copyrights and then look at
me
well if we didn't pay some copyrights
we'd have no incentive i go okay fine
but then you just told me that's a
policy so
you know but anyhow there's a tendency
just to treat it as this blob that like
oh
we have inequality and it's really
unfortunate even people on the left i
mean they want to have
progressive taxes which i think are
great but they
treat the underlying cause of inequality
as being something that's intrinsic to
the market
as opposed it was how we structured the
market yeah and it's amazing how i mean
when you talk about economics
invariably climate change comes up when
you talk about national security
invariably climate change comes up and
it is a it's an issue with uh
far far reaching tentacles for sure um
we've been speaking with economist dean
baker who's a senior economist at the
center for economic and policy research
also a visiting professor at the
university of utah
dean i really appreciate your time today
thanks a lot for having me on i really
enjoyed the discussion